buenos días
pero yo
jamás olvidaré argentin
en que por primera vez
me llamo más
quizás porque no la voy a olvidar
sencillamente por una razón porque era
este pobre niño ni caso de ese proyecto
en este caso finalmente porque
consideraba que en este momento los
maestros eran unas personas tan
importantes eran unas personas con una
paciencia y una sabiduría que en mi
contra yo no podía encontrar dentro de
mí esa situación que me hiciera conocer
o ser un maestro
tenemos escasos 22 años de edad ahora
estoy en historia y metido
eran los primeros inicios como maestro
si se me nota la cara bonita
este
dice
en el momento en que esa persona me
llamó maestro cambió mi vida para
siempre
los propios tenemos una gran sabiduría y
tenemos una gran paciencia mis
compañeros están ahí enfrente fueron los
primeros que tuve y fueron los que me
ayudaron a lograr
lo que poco a poco he estado logrando a
través de mi formación docente
mi nombre es licenciado adrián esteban
montes soy licenciado en la educación de
la universidad pedagógica nacional en la
ciudad de en ciudad cuadras
y mantenemos
de 60
las fuertes y esas aguas
muy enérgica
hasta que un día se me ocurrió llevar a
tablas
en este momento
10 y vueltas tienen algo especial las
abuelas
nunca
con el cariño las abuelas en uncas
probadores
hoy en día tenemos un gran espacio de
discusión entre lo que es la educación y
la calidad y lo podemos ver por todos
lados
[Música]
sin embargo creemos en la educación y la
calidad tiene que ver específicamente
con el mundo gasta
en oración
a lo mejor esta escuela
uno más
y más
es mejor docente
maestrías y doctorados a una educación
esto de la calidad educativa dos
panoramas
y este
la aplicación
en la familia
en el saludar y no se acuerda porque
llegará en familiares a tu casa y
forzosamente de opinión saludar a cada
uno de ellos hoy en día es muy raro que
nuestros hijos o nuestros jóvenes hagan
lo mismo porque sea
esa parte de los valores de salud o de
valores
estar presente este momento que ha
pasado hoy en día con la educación
[Música]
lo que ha pasado es
de lo que es la verdad de la educación
tenemos ahí
es bueno trabajar
dios
efe como de escuela federal
y
donde hay niños con necesidades
especiales y con una pobreza
esta escuela privada
también llegaba a las 7 de la mañana
de saltado
después del desayuno activar estación
primero
si ella es
de la primaria
[Música]
ah
terminando la comida se pasaba sus
actividades extraescolares
[Música]
sofía
y hasta la siguiente de la tarde
sofía recomienda por sus padres
esos días
y dentro de veces
sofía no vivía en su casa
sofía media como compartían a todos sus
amigos
bien
y algunas más
en particular
te voy a mandar a otra parte después de
ceder
i
o no
martino
sofía no llega a la nada
se me ha llegado nada
su vientre
[Música]
y sofía
siempre
nos tuvimos que quedarnos ahí
no
en particular
y una escuadra federal una escuela de
gobierno
de bajar a pisar a la mejor educación
para tus hijos
la educación no imágenes web en la que
se está en la calidad como padres
tenemos con nuestros hijos
si te fijas la situación es exactamente
la misma
de 7 a 100 de sofía la escuela
particular pero siempre sofía después
diferentes situaciones sociales
de situaciones económicas
la misma situación de alarma
y entonces nos exigir una educación de
calidad
la importancia de familia
al momento de estar con nuestros hijos
de que el vínculo que existe entre
padres e hijos mejoró notablemente
nos abre
y esto y finalmente
la familia aparece como
espacio privilegiado de desarrollo
y ahora somos
las redes sociales han tomado el control
del casino
cuántos de nosotros hemos visto algún
niño
entonces nosotros nosotros
y salado
presentaremos a nuestro hijo para
utilizar
cuántos de nosotros de comprarse una
tabla de nuestros hijos
tienes a nuestros hijos en una tablet o
quiénes de nuestros hijos tienen algún
aparato electrónico adecuado se pueden
divertir
a veces viene
muy bien
en mi mano
a la educación
hay que retomar el control de nuestros
hijos/as de lo que nosotros
[Música]
finalmente la educación de la abuela se
basaba en eso se basa en el respeto se
basada en la familia se basaba en las
relaciones cercanas entre los miembros
[Música]
había reuniones entre primos llamados
indies
y ahora
el vínculo y la familia
no más
importante
una parábola
cuatro personas
y leyendas
entrando en cada una de las cuatro
personas
imaginen una vez
y piensa por favor
a ti
en otras cuatro personas que se puedan
hacer cargo de turismo
bien
cuántas personas el poder acercarlo
de los hijos
y se necesitan 4
y
porque se me ha pasado la ventana
nuestros hijos también en el soporte de
la familia
así siempre depende solamente de las
palas y si como padres lo único que
hacemos es dejarlos de 7
[Música]
y bueno
algo que perjudica a nuestros niños
los dejo con esta reflexión de una
maestra chihuahuense que se llama
genoveva cosas
y dice lo siguiente
es mi segunda casa
denominadas
mi primera
es bueno
y para estos tiempos no hay mejor
educación cómoda buena educación
mira
[Aplausos]